And so if we have come from other engines and we're wanting to get
started with Unreal, or maybe you have a brief familiar with Unreal, but you're
not quite sure about the game framework, let's look at the game framework and
the, uh, how it actually operates inside of Unreal Engine.
So, um, to talk about the gameplay framework, uh, Unreal's framework is,
uh, essentially a collection of classes that provides you with a modular
foundation upon which to build your gameplay experience.
So, um, you can decide to opt in to what elements you need for your game.
And what's really foundational about Unreal Engine is that Unreal and
Epic Games ship their own games.
So, you know, they have experience based on Unreal, very early on,
so Unreal Tournament, and you may have found, um, heard of a recent
game called Fortnite, um, but essentially Epic makes its own game.
So the formula, you know, especially with Fortnite on the latest engine
versions, um, the Unreal Engine battle tests all the Fortnite elements first
and then ships those features to support that so you know that you're
getting battle tested features out of the box, but it is useful to think
about Epic's origins when thinking about the different gameplay framework
classes, because you'll see how the foundations were actually
built and, um, architected around.
So with Unreal Engine by default is built to be a network game
ready, uh, platform out of the box.
So if you think about these titles, such as Unreal Tournament, uh, the
structure does make a lot of sense and not all the architecture will
always be relevant to the game you're making, but understanding why you
might use, uh, a different system and when can be helpful to understand
the scope and also how you might architect your project moving forward.